In previous videos, we talked about different
solutions we have for living in Project Kamp.
Some people come with their own vans
and othersbring just tents...
In this video, we're going to prototype and install a custom tent,
on top of adeck in a different area of the land.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
So, we want to make ourtents for several reasons...
An important one is to provide a solution for us,
that can be replicatedby others.
So we will share the design drawings,
and information on how to make it.
Now, let me tellyou about what kind of tent we are going to build.
Camping tents are usually designed forshort stances.
For being carried easily in a light weight...
Easy to assemble and to disassemble.
Usually made out of plastic too...
They are low for the wind, and for easy transportation too...
So, that's something that really doesn't fit our needs...
And, after some researching in the market
and whatis out there...
We came up with the idea to design our own tent.
So, we want to design a tent forone person,
where you can stand to be more comfy.
We also want to use other materials,
because itdoesn't need to be carried around often.
So, for us, it's just setting it up at the beginning of theSeason,
putting it down at the end of the season.
We also want to make it not too big,
inorder to put it on top of a wooden platform.
To have it level, and increase the comfort inside.
This also would help us to keep it for a longer time.
So, the materials are not really touching thesoil or the ground...
Hopefully, this tent lasts way more years!
So, we have to choose whereto place the tent on our land...
We decided to go away from Basekamp,
to set it downin the field.
Next to the creek, and the yoga deck.
It's more a quiet and relaxedspace,
where you can hear nature sounds.
Away from noises, and the busy setup in Basekamp!
To build the deck, we went searching for our wood
from the local sawmill...
And we are takingit to the Kamp with our brand new pickup!
We are using red cedar with no treatment.
Because in the winter, our beloved roundabout sign
did very well and didn't get moldy.
So, we got the wood!
Now it's ready to be handed to Eemeli!
To be transforming our NEW tent decks!
Let's do it!
- Let's go!
Hi, I'm Eemeli!
I came to Project Kamp to workin both design and building.
That's also what I've been working on in Finland.
So, it's nice to continue withit in really different settings.
And to get a little more practice on these skills.
So, let's see how it goes!
Okay, now the wood is ready.
So next, we are gonna go and see the place.
Okay, now we are here in the bottom ofthe field.
And the first thing is to get rid of
the grass, and level the ground.
I found this metal wire...
Seems likesome kind of fence has been here...
I don't really know...
I think I willleave it for now and continue digging.
The ground work is now complete!
So, next we need to find a few rocks...
Okay, now we have all the rocks that we need...
So, now we can finally bring all the wood here!
The deck is now complete!
I think it looks nice!
I still want to do somegrass cutting,
to clean out the area a bit.
Okay, the deck is ready.
The wood is nottreated,
because we will use it as a test.
We want to compare it with anotherdeck close by...
Made with the same wood, but with industrial treatment.
Let'ssee how they behave in the long run!
Next, we need the tent to be created.
We askedKaegh and Eva for help.
They are very skilled, and also happen to be
good friends that live close by.
Theyhave a really nice camping side in the mountains!
Where they have installed a yurt,
and a big dome made by themselves.
So we thought it's a good idea that they take care of
building the canvas,and the tent frame.
Let's see how they work on it!
We are now waiting for Kaegh and Eva!
They're coming to bring the tent to the camp,
and build it on the location.
- Hello!
So, we made it!
Nice!
Now, we have all ofthe team in the Kamp!
Eemeli built the deck...
Eva made the canvas...
Kaegh made the frame...
Now we have all the pieces, and we need to put them together,
to build our tent on top of the deck!
Would it be cool later to mark the screws,
that we need to unscrew to disassemble it?
- Yeah, I was going to change the screws,
that you need to unscrew to bolts.
Where you do put in the bolts?
- So, we wanted tomake it as easy
as possible to disassemble...
So we're trying to have the bolts for the
temporary connections...
And then, everything else is either screwed or glued together...
So, then youonly need to take apart the bolts to take it down.
Hear that, Eva?
- Huh?
You did a super nice job!
- Aw, thank you!
So as you can see here in the wood,
we drilled these pieces in.
And this is then the other side of the
buttons that are onthe fabric.
So, the fabric is really easy, just like a button.
You can just press it in andit's connected to the wood.
Okay, so, this is the tent!
We've set it up, and it's basically done!
I sewed some strings here,
so you can just tie it...
This is one piece...
I did them separately,
butthen I sewed them together here.
And as you can see it has all buttons on it!
So you can really easily attach the fabric to the wood.
I chose to make three pieces, because it seemed easier.
Also, the velcro was kind of consciously chosen instead of a zipper...
A zipper might beeasier to use,
but I've honestly never installed a zipper...
And velcro is easier...
And if somethinggoes wrong with the zipper,
it's very hard to put in a new one.
But velcro is very easy to just...
to order is cheap, and to sew it in.
But, of course, you can use a zipper,
ifyou're comfortable with doing that.
So, then this is just a big piece!
It's like5,5 meters long!
If I'm correct, it's a semi-flat felled seam.
It's a waterproof seam!
You can really easily look up also in YouTube
how to makewaterproof seams.
As you can see, it's a bit too big basically...
But I did that on purpose,
to have like abit of an overlap.
So there is less space for gaps...
We only have like one button here,
but Iwould recommend doing more buttons along the way...
We added this strap to hold down
the fabric to the wooden structure.
So the strap is then attached to the base,
andkind of ties everything together...
I wanted to make the structure completely out of wood.
So, I made all of these triangular connections.
So these basically holdthe frame together,
to give it lateral stability.
And then these hold the beams in place,
to giveit support in the other direction.
And yeah, it was nice to kind of try
and make everythingfrom wood.
This was wood that I already had...
We had these removable bolts, so that
everything can be easily taken apart
But it's a prototype...
And we wanted to try and come up withsomething
with what we had and then something that could be.
And then, to further secure the frame,
webolted it down in four corners to the platform.
So, then it kind of has four anchoring bolts...
So, I madea window!
For extra ventilation, and it's just nice
to have a see-through, I think....
You can closeit fully, like this...
It's pretty strong velcro, I have to say...
This is waterproof, it's a hundred percent cotton!
I thinkit's 340 grams...
Mold resistant!
Also, when it rains a lot the fibers tend to grow!
Whichmakes it extra waterproof.
But then it can also shrink a bit... The fabric.
So it's alsogood to keep in mind that it could shrink...
Especially in length, to make everything
a bit more longer than it's needed, I would say...
Hello guys!
- Hello!
Hello!
- The tent is done!
- What do you think?
This is lovely!
It's amazing!
Wow! Love it!
Now we have our tent prototype!
We will see how it goes during the season.
For sure, some people from the Kampwill give it a try,
and tell us how it is to sleep in this cozy and beautiful space.
You can get more deep information
on how to makethe tent in the research module.
Follow the link in the description!
Next update will be an '8th-number' -video.
So we will talk about challenges we have...
And also answer some questions,
that you canask by commenting on this video.
You can address them to the different themes of our project...
Like video making, workspace, landscaping or kitchen.
Also, you can just ask and we will see who answers!
Thanks for watching, and see you in the next update!